hello everyone welcome back to the
collider youtube channel for another
tiff 2021 interview i am beyond thrilled
to be talking to the director and the
producer behind dash cam rob savage
douglas cox welcome to the channel and
congratulations on your film hey terry
thanks thanks for having us i am so
excited to talk to you guys so first i
have to obviously reference host and i
want to know why dash cam to follow a
post actually
rob was this the movie that you were
referring to when you said one other
project could have gone first before
host
um it was a project that we had we had a
kind of very rough idea for this film a
one pager that we that we'd worked out
uh that we were pitching pitching out
before anyone had heard the word covered
and um and nobody was interested you
know we pitched it to um
we pitched it to all the places you'd
expect and none of them none of them
were we're interested we were pitching
we were pitching it as a web series at
some point and then as a movie and it
just kind of like was one of those ideas
that float about for a little bit and
then disappear
and um
and then you know towards the end of
making hosts it's such such a kind of
lovely experience
working on host and working with that
team of people
that i wanted to find something that was
kind of in that mould but a bit of an
elevation and a bit of a different beast
but we could kind of make it using the
same momentum that we had from host and
with the same collaborators and and this
project seemed like something
something that we could do and we could
benefit from a bigger budget from from
blumhouse but could still be made in
that kind of nice
homemade intimate way that we made host
and um
and it kind of grew from there i mean
really the really the pitch was just uh
you know it was just about a live
streamer who um
who runs afoul of a of a demon it wasn't
it wasn't particularly sketched out but
um but it felt like
it felt like a nice challenge to go from
something where you're literally just
inside your homes to something that's uh
that's a road movie that's a chase movie
it felt like kind of a fun thing to get
thing to do it was certainly a challenge
i feel like that's all you guys know how
to do especially with with screen life
material so
so douglas uh rob brings this idea for
you to you what do you
circle on the script in red and say you
know this in particular this is going to
be an even bigger challenge even though
we had so much experience working with
this type of content on host
yeah i mean it's interesting because
like it was similar to host the way this
sort of those early stages came about
you know rob
along with with gemma hurley and jed
shepherd they were kind of working on
the story and um chatting with annie and
and sort of you know building that
framework up and and at the same time
you know we were turning around
production and figuring out
locations rob was like trying to like
just like putting all these tweets out
and all these
random people around the uk were like
coming back with these mad places that
we could maybe go and
a lot of that really dynamically built
up all of the the things that we could
do
uh or we could attempt and then and then
you know as as these things started
popping up you know rob would
phone me up and be like so you know
what about this and and a lot of it
would then yeah constantly evolving
process yeah and and we obviously have
all these um
wonderful hods and collaborators you
know most of whom we worked with on host
as well and lots of new people as well
because we scaled up you know quite
significantly on this one and
you know rob's rob style is always like
you know
what what can you offer it's this like
real kind of there's a real
joy to the collaboration on this and i
think it really
it doubles down on on what we did with
host which was
i think just a real triumph of
faith-based filmmaking where you bring
together a team of people
you know each other you trust each other
and
figure out the craziest most batch of
things that you can do together uh and
yeah it was
my challenge shooting out in the middle
of the second uk lockdown we had a team
of people traveling around the uk and
um and just a huge huge amount of um you
know credit to them all because you know
we shot for five weeks for for our
principal shooting
in really really difficult conditions
with a very small team and they all
really really looked out for each other
a cast crew and and we got through it
all with no um no cases so it was a real
it's a real marked pride i think on this
production and a real testament to
everyone who took part i have a million
questions about the elaborate set pieces
you guys crammed into this movie but
backtracking a bit to the scripting
phase rob i'm curious what was it like
for you moving beyond the time limit of
a zoom call after host did
did you find that freeing or maybe the
lack of definition in that respect being
maybe overwhelming
it was a little overwhelming it was it
was more about just trying to find the
language of the movie you know the the
um
with host the nice thing is that it was
it was really clear because it was
exactly you know it had to feel like a
real zoom call and had to feel exactly
like the zoom calls that everyone was
was sitting on day in day out during a
lockdown so it was a very specific
feeling to aim for whereas um
you know with with dashcam
you know for one it's a single camera
film it's one it's one live stream that
we
uh we cut into and sometimes we play
long so some scenes are kind of tricked
to look like long elaborate single takes
and some uh
some scenes are much more jagged and and
you know and and jump cutty and
improvisational and it was about kind of
like finding
that um
but find you know finding the balance
between like letting annie's personality
as well start to shape the film as she
started to um
you know she became the kind of crucial
collaborator who came on during the
shoot and and you know just like with
host
we had a beat sheet of bullet points
that we you know we didn't we didn't
really reference it while we were
shooting we didn't have sides we didn't
um
we didn't turn up and say this is what
we were doing every day we would turn up
and discover it with um with the cast
and crew and improvise and find
find what the film phone what the film
ultimately ultimately is and um and so
much of that was
something that was on the day and summit
was
just talking constantly to brennaranga
our amazing editor who did host as well
who was editing as we as we were
shooting and we would kind of chat every
night about what was working what wasn't
working we'd try and find
the language of the film and how the
edits were were working and what kind of
um
what kind of coverage would give us the
best shot
and i think off the back of that as well
like one of the really lovely things
about host and i think it's again
testament to the support from the you
know the places behind like so um you
know bum house were incredible with this
one and
knowing that we were going into shoot
with no dialogue made it like kind of
impossible to do dailies and and sort of
you know like those kind of notes where
you can really get a sense of the exact
length of something and rob being
allowed to
create an environment and a film that
was able to to find its its best length
like naturally and organically and and
really embrace the the kind of chaos of
it you know and let annie do her thing
and and uh you know find all these
really like incredible things that you
could never uh
you know describe you could never script
you know some of some of her madness and
uh
that was really you know it was a real
privilege
speaking of that madness i'm sure you're
getting a lot of this right now but i do
have to ask what was the motivation
behind making your main character as
controversial as annie
i just think there's no harm in in
in spending time with people who don't
have the same opinion as you and i think
that at some point in the very near
future
we're going to hit a wall where there's
going to be a certain chunk of the
population that aren't going to get
vaccinated and we're going to have to
live shoulder to shoulder with people
who
demonstrably don't share our values live
in a slight you know a reality that's
slightly off from our own and um
and also you know annie's annie's
playing a much more kind of cartoonish
version of herself in this in this movie
she's um
you know she's she's got just a genius
mind that was that was that was key in
the same way to same way you know as on
host we had this group of friends who
had this this really nice natural easy
chemistry that i relied on so much day
in day out when i was when i was shaping
the film um
you know working with annie relying on
her wit and her spontaneity and her
creativity was was huge and essential
and you know we wouldn't have been able
to to make this film
um in the way that we did
without her um
so you know i think it's important to
talk about annie i think as a
collaborator on this movie and not the
subject of this movie she's not you know
we're not making a documentary about
annie she's um
uh
you know she's a much more uh
she's a much less abrasive character in
real life and she is in the movie i
think it was an interesting one for me
like kind of going into this and the
conversations at the beginning were you
know is it going to be annie or are we
going to find an actor and and like kind
of
you know it's a it's kind of a wild you
know move in a way to to to step into a
space like this um
with someone who's like not got that
kind of huge background in um in acting
and she's obviously just this incredible
performer and with all of her other kind
of work that goes on and and then you
know a lot of the other cast around her
as well like it was uh again it it found
itself quite well and and and just being
able to to sort of set rob off with
these people each day and you've seen
it was really wonderful to see a lot of
that evolve um
you know through the camera you know as
we were shooting just to follow up on
something you just said douglas was
there was there a time when you were
collaborating with annie on developing
the project but weren't necessarily sure
that she was going to star in it
well the original idea because she she
actually does this show ban car where
she drives around and improvises music
and um
you know
when
when i first
judge showed me showed me the show and
the first kind of conversations were
like oh that's a cool setup for a fan
footage movie and the you know the
version we were kind of taking around
pre-host was very much just using the
band car setup um but the idea was to
probably you know to probably take it to
studios to probably try and get an actor
to play that role um
and then it was really kind of like
the experience i had working with the
cast of host
and
and really kind of inviting that level
of collaboration from from the the cast
made me
made me think that like you know the way
to the way to do this movie and to make
it something different and something
something exciting and something a bit
dangerous is like
it's doing is to fully engage with annie
and let this film carry her personality
and let you know the same way the host
when i think about host i think about
that group of girls
when i think about dash cam i think it
really captures the mad chaos of annie
hardy which you know whether that's a
good thing or a bad thing is is down to
the viewer but um
it's you know that was the intention
going in and i think just to speak you
know on on that as well like
i have a huge amount of respect to annie
for for trusting us to to kind of to
work with her in this way like you know
we met obviously virtually um you know i
spent some time with her chatting on
zoom and obviously um gemma and rob and
jed spent a bunch of time chatting with
her and and talking through things and
you know it was a it was difficult like
you know we were shooting at a time
where a lot of the rules are only just
beginning to form in the uk about how we
could um like manifest a production in
the middle of covid and there was lots
of
lots of changing fluctuating kind of
rules and conditions and you know it was
we asked a lot of people annie included
annie especially in fact you know she
was coming over there's lots of
quarantines huge amounts of testing
going on and i think it's uh
you know like
it was that collaboration again like she
fully like um stepped into our gang for
the film and like really kind of
became a became a real part of that film
family is as you always do with with
these kind of shoots it's um like and
like you said she you know she
whatever her belief she followed the the
testing regimen we had no cases on the
shoot it was um yeah she's super
respectful
i have a very specific question about
the live stream element now
rob what was it like figuring out
precisely when to disconnect and
reconnect the stream other than when the
action of the film necessitates it how
did you decide when you wanted her
viewers to be able to see what was
happening to her
we had we had i think i think there's
like four disconnects in the movie or
three disconnects
and i think two of two of them
two of them i kind of like plotted quite
early on you know there was there was
the moment um
the moment when it first happened which
you know the first time that we're left
alone in the whole movie
which i just wanted to feel like this oh
this holy [ __ ] we're on our own kind of
moment and it was it just happens um as
something there's something
you know because the whole thing the
whole thing with the light with a live
stream is
as soon as something happens that the
audience can see
that that's really uh
you know that's proof of something
supernatural um everyone within the
movie world sees it as well so you have
to you have to play breadcrumbs for the
first half of the movie in terms of um
what you can show because if you see
somebody get their head pulled off on a
live stream too early the police are
gonna get caught there's gonna be real
world ramifications so
there's a point of the movie where
things really start to really start to
amp up
um and you start you know we wanted the
audience to see something that nobody
else is privy to
and then to be left alone especially
since it's our first sequence in the
middle of the woods and this is also
this is also a movie that scratches my
my like lifelong desire to make a scary
roaming around the woods by torchlight
movie and i wanted that bit to just be
just be me in the audience um and then
um
and then you know and then i knew that i
wanted the kind of final stretch
um
to really be annie
without a friend left in the world you
know um
bedraggled and and you know on her own
and to feel the isolation of that
and uh
and then there was a middle one and then
there was there was one in the middle
that me and brenna the editor just made
up because we were like this is too busy
let's just get rid of it did you ever
ask brenna
what what she found more difficult
editing host or editing uh editing dash
cam
um no
maybe i did i think she probably i think
she'd probably say host i think dash cam
dash cam was difficult i think because
i was allowed to be in the room so i was
i was there to like to sit over her
shoulder and but um
but no i think with like dashcam was
dashcam was like editing with bren on
dashcam was a blast like it was so like
so nice as well as soon as the russians
started to come in and she started to
see what we were doing
with annie and how we were kind of
placing annie
you know this character that you
wouldn't normally see in the middle of a
of a horror narrative we're plonking her
in the middle of this you know otherwise
quite quite conventional horror story um
you know i didn't i kind of like i i'd
shown brenna some of annie's stuff but
when the russians started coming in just
brenner just totally got it straight
away and totally got and he's humor and
totally got annie's kind of
um anarchic streak and uh and you know
the first a lot of the first stuff we
shot was the um
you know the first 20 minutes of the
movie and brenda was sending these just
[ __ ] so so
funny and energetic first cuts in like
so much of what's so much of the first
20 minutes the movie is
pretty much what brennan sent me on our
first assembly and it's funny actually
there's like i mean it's obviously very
different but there's a lot of
similarities to to host in terms of the
way that process work because that early
stuff where it was lots of improv lots
of playing around we had so much more
like gold there and it was a really
interesting exercise in like stepping
that horror narrative forwards if like
you know or just saying with annie for
so long but i mean that yeah
to speak on the comments as well like it
was a
that was a monumental challenge that so
many people you know need to take some
credit for but dan hawkins in particular
who uh
was our kind of animator on that and and
we basically had to create our own
bespoke piece of software to run this
because it was so
involved and so high scale in terms of
the amount of information coming through
like on host
we placed every single graphic and there
were about four thousand but this is all
animated it's all moving
and we needed to be able to change
things and i mean it was
one of the one of the hardest things
i've ever had to do and i'm like just
having a little moment of ptsd thinking
about it now but i'm just just
[Laughter]
but it was also just you know i i'm
really delighted
where it's ended up because like
hopefully audiences will get an
opportunity to see this again and again
and you can watch this film
quite a few times and and there's lots
of fun things to take away from that
section in particular i will tell you 15
minutes is not enough to discuss this
production but i am determined not to
derail your tip schedule right now so
i'm gonna say congratulations and thank
you for chatting with us about dashcam
thank you so much